Student Vincent schwarz und
Bundeswehrsoldat Biland AIDA 7 helfen
sich jetzt selbst der Corsa ist in die
Jahre gekommen der Motor nicht mehr ganz
dicht für die Reparatur haben sie sich
eine Hebebühne der Hobbywerkstatt
Mainz-Bingen gemietet
wir tauschen heute in
kühlmittelpflanzung und zwei Dichtungen
bei der Wagen Kühlmittelverlust hatte
und Ölverlust genau ja wie würdest du
das Einordnen sind das schwere
mittelschwere leichte Aufgaben also
schon ähm ja mittelschwer würde ich
sagen ja also ist jetzt keine
alltäglichen Arbeiten die Bremsen
wechseln oder Ölwechsel ja das ist schon
äh ja bisschen anspruchsvoller
anderthalb Stunden zuvor die beiden
hobby-schrauber haben sich Ersatzteile
besorgt die kann man sich selbst
mitbringen oder man bestellt sich hier
direkt vor Ort denn in der Halle neben
den miethebebühnen befindet sich auch
die Werkstatt des Betreibers und
KFZ-Meisters Manuel
ich habe da auch drei Angestellte und
wenn da wenn es hier mal irgendwo hakt
oder was nicht funktioniert dann können
die Kunden auch gerne zu uns rüberkommen
und fragen uns wir helfen mit wir gucken
drüber wir kontrollieren die Arbeit die
gemacht wurde auf bei Bedarf
und das hat man den anderen
Hobbywerkstatt halt meistens nicht die
Kosten hier Miete für eine Hebebühne und
Werkzeug 1750 pro Stunde genau richtig
für sein Projekt findet
die Dichtung haben wir 12 € gekostet das
also nicht das teure
das teure ist halt in der Werkstatt dann
die Arbeit wenn man überlegt so eine
Stunde in der Werkstatt kostet
vielleicht auf jeden Fall mehr als 50
Euro und die Teile kosten 12 da steht ja
eigentlich in keinem Verhältnis
vier Hände sind besser als zwei meinen
die beiden deshalb sind sie häufiger
gemeinsam hier die Hilfe für Kumpel
Vincent für Bilanz Ehrensache das
Konzept der Hobbywerkstatt findet er
einfach nur gut
ich habe das schon Freund mitbekommen
der das selber im Internet glaube ich
auf Facebook gesehen hat dass er was
geteilt wurde und da haben uns auch
selber sehr gewundert weil ähm wir
schrauben generell selber an unsere
Fahrzeuge bevor wir andere Werkstatt
jetzt ran lassen weil wir die arbeiten
ja selber können die eigene
Arbeitsleistung sich einfachere
Reparaturen zuzutrauen das sei der
springende Punkt meinen die
hobby-schrauber ich würde auch nicht
jetzt Arbeiten machen
aber so Ölwechsel persönlich bremsen und
so das sind so arbeiten die kann ich
selber machen und kann mir dabei voll
viel Geld sparen und das müssen in
Zeiten wie diesen immer mehr Menschen
weiß Betreiber Manuels aber zu berichten
es wird jetzt wirklich von Woche zu
Woche merkt man Zuwachs an Kunden und
jeder muss im Moment gucken wo er sparen
kann und am Auto ist halt ein großer
Posten bei bringt man sein Auto eine
Werkstatt dann kann es mal schnell teuer
werden wenn man selbst auch überhaupt
Netz schrauben kann weil wir bei selbst
Abhilfe schaffen kann indem man sich
selbst ein Ölwechsel durchführt da kann
man schon einiges sparen im Endeffekt
und das merkt man halt den Ölwechsel
machen die beiden auch gleich mit wenn
der Wagen schon mal oben ist danach
rechnet Vincent schwarz vor was eine
Werkstatt wohl für diese Reparatur
berechnen würde das hätte jetzt gekostet
die je nachdem es kommt natürlich immer
drauf an so um die 500 € ja und jetzt
bin ich mitteilen bei um die 200 €
darin enthalten rund vier Stunden auf
der Bühne neues Öl und Kühlmittel
Entsorgung der Altlasten Ersatzteile sie
sind sich sicher das wäre viel teurer
geworden hätten sie nicht selbst
geschraubt